[Music]
there are those who dream and those who
turn their dreams into reality that's
what the henneman group is doing all
around the world designing unique and
unforgettable experiences
nothing is out of reach and the bigger
the fantasy the more their team is
encouraged to pull it off like their
latest creation which debuted this year
a glittering crystal lobby show at
galaxy macau in china i got to take a
look at some of their projects where the
sky isn't even the limit
from a high rolling ferris wheel in las
vegas to a dream water park in new
jersey to sparkling chandeliers at a new
resort in china if you imagine it the
hedema group will build it what we
really consider ourselves as
storytellers first and foremost and we
make stories in three dimensions here we
call it stories you can touch phil
henema followed his own dreams and
created the storytelling studio after
leaving attraction development at
universal studios i would guess that the
word no here is off limits
it certainly is at the beginning of a
project we have a rule in our
brainstorming that's no bad ideas
because we really want to stretch the
envelope and everything we do the spaces
need to be functional not just part of a
set projects can take five years or more
from development to standing tall like
the one world observatory in new york
city it took just over two years the
observatory in new york at the world
trade center was a really complicated
project because it didn't want to focus
on 911 but there wasn't a soul that was
going to go to that project that wasn't
painfully aware of where they were so
kind of trying to take that
and build on that idea but then
ultimately talked about we can now stand
on this site and look forward to a
brighter future was a pretty complicated
challenge so we're about to get on the
elevator which will take us 100 stories
in about 45 seconds
yes 1200 feet in about 45 seconds
depending on the wind jody roberta
started on the project well before
ground was ever broken this is a time
lapse history from the 1100s to today
everything from the native american
settlements to the growing
industrial revolution to a metropolis
filled with skyscrapers
so the minute you get here you're
immersed in the story welcome to one
world observatory and we're here already
winds of change was at the center of the
project when they started
conceptualizing a design back in 2013
that includes the see forever
theater it's almost like you're bringing
the city to life
the idea is to engulf the guests
in the heartbeat and the rhythms of the
life of new york and panoramic views of
manhattan
well that's a wow the first time we were
in here with real guests
they were standing ovations and that
happened
quite a bit it was a remarkable feeling
to experience that
with them for the first time every
detail was considered and visitors from
all over the world take it in every
single day
what do you think you'll take away today
wow
just the breathtaking views and you know
just this whole story behind you know
new york what did you think in the
theater when they rose the screens we
were lost for words literally i looked
at her and i said why am i crying she
says me too
hedema has projects all over the globe
in the world's largest indoor theme park
in south korea
to north america's largest indoor water
park an interactive exhibit in the famed
world war ii museum in new orleans and
smaller creations like a pop-up at union
station in los angeles what's the budget
in a lot of these
projects can go up to hundreds of
millions of dollars some of these are
big projects but you know if the story's
right it excites us creatively then you
know a few thousand dollars
can
put something pretty magical together
this year marks henema's 20th
anniversary and their goal remains the
same what's the end game just keep on
telling stories
all of us as human beings understand
life as stories every part of our daily
life we create a story out of it so
turning experiences into stories we're
lucky to be able to do that
that and catching the eye and letting
their projects open up an opportunity
for others to dream big we're first and
foremost in the experience business and
i think today particularly people are so
hungry to connect with each other
whether it's a fantastic dinner or that
moment on a roller coaster when you were
screaming for your life and we
experienced those because of the people
were around us and it makes that
connection with the people around us
that much more special and memorable and
that's really our business
and that's really what it is about for
them is bringing people together but
they think about every single little
detail so even at one world trade
the flooring they had to think about
what sounds would be on the floor if
somebody wore high heels or you know
whatever how would that change the
experience for people so when they go in
they think about everything and that's
the key i think is that it's not just
the one ride or one thing it's the whole
experience right i'm curious how this
story idea came came to evolve i mean
did you see something and say i wonder
how that works i have to say the
producer marianne on this one she i
think she dreamed it she she conceived
it and it turned out great i mean that i
think the diversity of projects when she
sent me this idea we started looking at
it and you think about something small
to something yeah i mean they do it all
so it's you know there's a little bit of
something for everybody i love it the
dream makers credit to marianne
you go girl